[Música]
en las calles sombrías de un
pueblo una madre presumía con orgullo de
su hijo recién nacido tras observar su
marca de nacimiento los vecinos
predijeron que se casaría con una
princesa pero los rumores No tardaron en
llegar a oídos del malvado rey El rey
enfurecido atrapó al niño y lo abandonó
río abajo pero la suerte del niño
resultó ser mayor que los planes del
Rey años después mientras el rey paseaba
por su reino divisó a un joven fornido
con una extraña marca de
nacimiento tras confirmar los orígenes
del niño el astuto rey le confió una
carta para la
reina El joven partió entusiasmado a
entregar el mensaje sin saber que lo que
llevaba era su propia sentencia de
muerte aquella noche unos bandidos que
vagaban por allí toparon con su
campamento pero en cuanto leyeron
aquella carta cruel les invadió la
lástima Así que decidieron mejor
molestar al rey y escribieron una nueva
carta cuando el joven llegó al palacio
cruzó una mirada con la princesa se
sintieron destinados el uno para el otro
y cuando la reina leyó que el rey
aprobaba aquel matrimonio organizó con
entusiasmo una boda sorpresiva cuando el
rey volvió estaba furioso pero no podía
ejecutar al amor de su hija sin
razón así que ideó una prueba
diabólica ordenó al joven ir al
mismísimo infierno y volver con tres
cabellos de oro recién arrancados de la
cabeza del
solo si lo conseguía podría
volver con su prometida El joven buscó
la entrada al infierno por todo el reino
Hasta que por fin divisó una Misteriosa
aldea allí vio a algunos campesinos
reunidos alrededor de un pozo lo
acorralaron y le impidieron El Paso
hasta que contestara la pregunta por qué
el pozo estaba
seco El joven respondió contestaré
cuando
regrese los campesinos guiaron al joven
aldea adentro donde encontró a otros
campesinos que contemplaban un árbol
nudoso se negaron a dejar pas hasta que
les respondiera la pregunta por qué el
árbol era
infértil de nuevo el joven respondió
contestaré cuando
regrese los campesinos lo guiaron hasta
el muelle donde un barquero anciano
esperaba mientras remaba por las aguas
negras el barquero arrojó una tercera
pregunta cómo puedo escapar de esta
tarea
interminable una vez más El joven
prometió estaré cuando
regrese al fin llegaron a un refugio
situado en las pantanosas orillas del
infierno El joven llamó a una puerta en
mal estado la abuela del contestó
a su llamada era conocida por ayudar a
algunos visitantes y hacer daño a otros
El joven acababa de terminar su historia
Cuando escucharon los pasos del
de repente el mundo parecía hacerse más
pequeño la abuela del subió al
joven a los pliegues de su manga y
saludó a su
nieto la anciana se puso a trabajar y
llenó al de comida y bebida
cuando este se quedó dormido le arrancó
hábilmente tres brillantes
cabellos con cada cabello que arrancaba
el despertaba brevemente y se
quejaba de sus sueños llenos de
campesinos de la zona y sus
problemas
a la mañana siguiente El joven marchó
con tres cabellos de oro y tres
datos compartió el primer sueño del
con el barquero si el barquero
conseguía dar los remos a algún pasajero
dispuesto quedaría liberado de su tarea
de vuelta en la ciudad El joven anunció
que allí había un ratón Rendo las raíces
del árbol y un gran sapo bloqueando el
pozo los campesinos compensaron
generosamente por su ayuda al regresar
de su viaje El joven le mostró al rey
los cabellos del pero su avaro
suegro solo tenía ojos para el
oro El astuto joven le dijo al rey que
una mayor fortuna lo esperaba cruzando
el río inmediatamente el rey se apresuró
a la orilla del río ansioso de reclamar
su fortuna tendió impaciente las manos
al barquero quien feliz Le entregó sus
remos para más viajes al Inframundo con
este video aprenda sobre el libro
egipcio de los muertos una guía antigua
destinada a facilitar una transición
plácida al más
allá